[Music]
[Music]
revenge does wonders for the will to
live don't you think yeah it's crazy how
successful it is that keeping people
alive in this franchise i hear in star
wars medical school they teach that for
all terminal diagnoses doctors should
make a choice between killing one of the
patient's family members or writing a
prescription to have someone kick the
patient's pet dog you'd be surprised how
many chews door number one show
literally starts on just a picture of
sand as if it's taunting me i feel like
the kid in jurassic park after the jeep
chased him down the tree except in this
case the jeep is tatooine and now we're
back in the sand again for a planet
where water is a commodity he sure is
pouring that carelessly
something you want to say remember him
he's the bully from a few episodes back
the one that was addicted to that one
guy when obi-wan did nothing about it
bet you haven't been able to sleep at
night wondering what happened to him and
if he'll ever be brought to justice well
here you are people don't ever say star
wars isn't giving you what you want i
don't have to do much research to figure
out that star destroyers come equipped
with a huge hangar filled with tie
fighters that vader is inexplicably
choosing to not utilize in this chase
upon further research i found out that
star destroyers can actually carry a
whopping 48 tie fighters so i think you
can guess how many sins are about to be
awarded
hyperdrive's almost ready ah yes the
non-functioning hyperdrive or as they
call it in the star wars writers room
the plot jesus how much time do you need
more than we have look that's a
non-answer which i guess is fine except
that both parties just pretend the
question is settled oh we should have
responded with no seriously i'm
brainstorming solutions here give me a
ballpark figure so i can at least
explore some options but instead he's
all cool bro thanks for the witty retort
i'm just gonna be over here aimlessly
wandering around and wistfully looking
at all these innocents if you want to
follow up here in a scooch
adult kneels in front of leia for a
profound conversation and we skip it
because we hate sentimentality cliche
but we're so close then maybe you should
have said that when obi-wan asked you
about it five minutes ago
you are all the future you are the
future teach them well and let them lead
the way
i decided long ago
never to work in anyone's shadow
if i fail if i succeed you you have my
word
although i know the word of a liar and a
fake dad i may not mean much to you
hajah would be one with the force at tv
since it's good enough for me sadly
obi-wan's chief character trait in this
series is a proclivity for leaving leia
with strangers and then wondering why
she keeps going missing how did she know
it was here i don't know all i know is
she's coming oh oh i can help see the
show needed something for riva to do
after the completion of her main story
motivation so it provided her with a
convenient message leading her directly
here for more sandy hijinks because they
didn't think the episode could survive
with just the single threat of the vader
kenobi stuff it's the whole modern thing
where climaxes can't just be about one
thing anymore and that's the intercua
between at least two and as many as five
things because audiences are used to
tick-tock where the attention spans
don't just jiggle jiggle they fold so
anyhow
what was the question again where enough
you and me they are not she'll come when
the suns go down
best we got position now of course it
will be after sundown because somehow
reeve is aware that all 21st century tv
shows have to be said in the near pitch
dark in order to be enjoyed why is
everything so dark i blame the clouds
get off my lawn
i have something for you adult knees in
front of leia for a profound
conversation and we skip it because we
hate cinematology cliche
um cliche
rokin found it before we got out she
would have wanted you to have it given
the choice i think what tala would have
actually wanted was a throwable grenade
so that she didn't have to needlessly
sacrifice herself also wait how the hell
dro can manage to find it intact wasn't
tala wearing it when she redecorated
that cavern well i wasn't gonna give you
a blaster layer you're 10 years old
don't you get all cocky kid you may
think that's ridiculous but this is like
big league chew all over again give a
kid shredded gum that looks like chewing
tobacco and then pretend that doesn't
have some sort of formative effect on
them when they eventually decide to
mainline nicotine through their gums
this would be like obi-wan giving leia a
bong and then getting all high and
mighty about not giving her some og kush
to go with it he sure does lounge around
pondering things a lot for someone
trying to save a shipload of people who
somehow still haven't been blown apart
by a freaking star destroyer whether he
dies or i do
this ends today it will not and i can
say this without even seeing the rest of
the episode because guess what we've
known how this feud in since 1977. why
are we trying to build any sort of
tension for this battle let's enjoy it
for what it is a chance to see ewan
mcgregor's obi-wan dueling fates with
darth vader stop trying to trick us into
believing there any actual stakes here
you don't have to do this you know poor
rokin his character's defined by
constantly trying to stop obi-wan from
doing something he's already decided
he's going to do armed with nothing but
the thinnest of overused platitudes
people follow you
don't stop
just get started this setup for disney
plus spinoff was so blatant they might
as well just froze the frame on his
smile and put the words coming soon to
disney plus on the screen coming fall
2023 rokin's an undercover mechanic
secretly working for the rebellion in
you can't fix what isn't broken now is
our chance to
wipe out this network in its entirety we
cannot prioritize one lone
jedi i mean he makes an excellent point
why can't vader chase down the wounded
rebel ship and then hunt down obi-wan he
knows obi-wan plans to distract him from
the rebel ship so wouldn't it demoralize
obi-wan even more to know that he'd
failed and essentially abandoned his
friends to die also you could just
launch the tie fighters the tuscans are
on the hunt again they're raiding farms
along the waist that's racist did booker
boba fett teach us nothing don't answer
that prepare my ship i will face him
alone because my hubris lines up nicely
with the need for a cinematic showdown
coming spring 2024 to disney plus lola
infiltrates the empire and destroys them
one ship at a time in droid where
prohibited have you come to destroy me
obi-wan
i will do what i must
he did the thing he did the thing
yes
get it obi-wan [ __ ] him up this is so
freaking cool and it's so good to
finally see an extended light so for
[ __ ] sake what are we doing back here
i don't know if i want to complain that
owen and beru somehow can't even hit her
when they have the element of surprise
and the high ground or if i'd rather
complain about the fact that riva
literally took a lightsaber to the gut a
few minutes ago so really where's the
tension with this puny blaster fire all
right i'm me i get to complain about
both did you truly think that you could
defeat me
you have failed
master masturbating
what why isn't he gone already beru knew
that owen defeating riva was as likely
as a star wars show not visiting
tatooine so why wasn't luke already out
of there as soon as you heard them
fighting even the rocks in action movies
suffer from one at a time items wait why
is obi-wan continually hitting him with
the butt of his lightsaber once or twice
is fine but if he has time to repeatedly
do this then he has time to slice vader
in half unless he's been pulling his
punches swings this whole time but that
makes even less sense i'm sorry attic
i am not your failure obi-wan
you
didn't kill anakin
skywalker
i did
this moment alone is almost worth the
five episodes of mediocrity we had to
endure to get it mcgregor really gives
us the catharsis of obi-wan finally
finding a way to forgive himself in the
fact that that release comes
unintentionally from anakin himself it's
a beautiful book into the relationship
as master and apprentice strike me down
if you will but i'll come back stronger
and still remove a sin and my friend is
truly dead cool so you're gonna kill
this abhorrent dangerous and genocidal
being that's not your friend right i
swear the defining characteristic of
these two's relationship is their
inexplicable need to leave each other
alive for the next battle where's the
mortal kombat announcer when you need
him guys she's gonna kill luke oh no i
can't look tell me when it's over
because i'm so scared that this
pointless exercise will never be over
i'll look in the dune see we'll search
till we find him this is the equivalent
of obi-wan saying i'll search the sahara
desert for him and then leaving on foot
instead of using the
spaceship he just landed in and looking
out the window have i become him
now
who you become now
who's up to you coming fall 2024 to
disney plus a former youngling gets
inquisitive about what's next in life in
revamped she's literally vader without
the d will people please stop leaving
their deadly death sticks in the middle
of a [ __ ] desert to be found by any
passing child jawa or tuscan i serve
only you
my master and cue the inevitable
imperial march theme if disney has a
strategy document for star wars i
wouldn't be surprised if it was
literally titled playing the hits giving
the fans what they think they want
without trusting that what they may
actually want is something original with
just a light sprinkling of a nostalgia
that's a bit lengthy but it's printed on
a1 size paper for everyone in the back
row
combing your already perfectly braided
hair
kids so is the whole being the most
recognizable jedi in the galaxy thing
not a problem anymore nba young ob is
just out here like i ain't scared come
get me well if you ever need my help
again
you know where to find me let's hope
that day never comes sir if your only
hope is this vague hope then may i
advise that you perhaps look for a new
hope
[Music]
kneeling to leia's level three times in
one episode it's time for the hype
[Music]
uh guys our
hyperskip generator appears to have gone
down and honestly my motivator has been
busted for a while now so i ain't fixing
it just uh do the normal scene and let's
move on will i ever see you again does
disney milk every ip cow in its barn
until the udders fall off sorry was she
asking a rhetorical question i've always
wondered what these cubes were supposed
to be or what their function is i feel
like it has something to do with cake
what are you uh doing here right i was
just saying this so not only does he go
to alderaan to put leia in danger he
just heads over to the skywalker ranch
to make sure luke's got a target on his
back as well hello there
master qui-gon waiting until the last
possible second to take off the last two
items on your things that apparently
need to happen in an obi-wan kenobi
series bingo card i was always here
obi-wan
we just
we're not ready to see
coming as soon as we can convince him to
disney plus a former jedi master finally
gets an offer he can't refuse in qui-gon
but not forgotten this time liam's ready
to cash that check
i'm getting better no you're not you'll
be stone dead in a moment
fire everything
howdy i'm woody howdy howdy
howdy no
he is not just any jedi he's a very
naughty boy
hello there hello there hello there
hello there why do you doubt your senses
because a little thing affects the
slight disorder of the stomach makes
them cheats you may be a bit of
undigested beef